[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome to the what podcast more taco
berry quarter I'm Brad a podcast about
music festivals music industry inside
baseball and hair
it's a good day it's looking around the
room it's a good day look at that yeah
I'm kidding
so I want to start uh because I know
we've got a lot of things to get into by
the way nice to see you guys I haven't
seen you guys I know I'm so happy to be
about a full house
the most important thing though to talk
about first and foremost is
PBR has a new can
yeah uh oh
what do you mean what okay all right let
me back up for a second so Barry uh Taco
sends me a picture the other night of
PBR in a new can
a whole new designer can
and he's happy about it or not happy
that's what I'm trying to find out Taco
your official review of the new can yeah
they do this every year they have an art
contest they let people vote on the uh
the art and then the winner they put on
the can for a season why aren't you on
the can
[Laughter]
you you know and get me in there you
have a head and put that cartoon hat on
the can yeah I think we know people
somebody please design us a PBR Lord
Taco can I'm begging you we'll submit it
for the art project and then maybe this
time next year you're going to be on the
PBR can man that'd be great that would
be pretty great that's that'd be better
than me on the milk carton
yeah I it would be one of those moments
where Taco look around like yeah I'm
done here check yeah everything else in
my life I'm done the Lord Taco PBR
collectible can
oh God that swells my heart he's
thinking about it I'm so excited
might he do that for us I think it would
taste a little bit better with with my
face on it I'm not sure I could drink it
I I just have to stare at it
well I'll be totally honest with you I
don't really as much as I love you I
don't want anything of Lord Taco that
close to my mouth
nor should you yeah that's true that's
true I don't know where this has been
huh
probably you do yeah you probably do
yeah what's what's the born on date on
this thing
well that's exciting news that would be
that would be a bucket list item for
taco I can't believe I'm saying this and
I I I I don't want to bring it up and
when I say I don't want to bring it up I
absolutely want to bring it up
um guys uh I hit a Mount Rushmore
a Mount Rushmore of my life uh two weeks
ago actually two weeks ago yesterday
I became best friends with Bill Murray I
know we saw pictures yeah we talked
about it we saw people we talked about
it and did you Taco pointed out that uh
it didn't look like the normal
selfie where you know you ambushed him
and he was not happy about it he
actually looked like you were having a
conversation we had a long long
conversation and uh I'll just tell you
my Bill Murray story really quick
quickly because I love telling the story
um so we're at the Phoenix show and I'm
talking to the guy after the show that
from Phoenix the bass player from
Phoenix and he's a sweetheart and I love
this band so much so we're just
chit-chatting about the band and going
back and forth and he looks over my
shoulder and goes oh look there's Bill
Murray
and I go no no it's not give me a break
don't worry it's not here I'm not even
turning around to justify what you just
said because again and not again not
again and then he goes and he goes no
seriously it's Bill Murray and I turn
around I see Bill Murray I turn back to
the Phoenix Sky I said see you later and
I run to Bill Murray and so we get to
Bill and he's like he's getting he's
getting manhandled by this woman and I
she just won't let him out of her grasps
right so he talk and talk and talk and
talk and so I'm not going to interrupt
them so he we take a lap around the room
we come back to Bill Murray and by that
time there is the there's these dudes
who are uh like like bro dudes and they
break up the conversation they're you
know being jerks and then Bill Murray
gets the wife my wife to take a picture
of them and you know she may she cracks
a joke makes Bill Murray laugh and that
gives us the end to go after Bill Murray
and so we start talking and and
I I can't explain to you it's like he
was right out of Central Casting if
somebody were to cast Bill Murray he's
the perfect Bill Murray he's everything
that you think that he is he's he's
Charming he's hysterical
um so I start I start just cracking
jokes I call him prime minister nice to
meet you prime minister uh people walk
up to him like this is Gary Murray don't
tell anybody and he he starts to really
start cocking his head it's like what is
going on with this dude and then finally
I start petting him
you touched it very he's very wearing a
very fluffy shirt so I'm petting him and
I look at he he looks at me he's like
what are you doing I was like I'm
petting Bill Murray
you can't wear a fluffy shirt if you're
if you're Bill Murray because everyone
will want to pet Bill Murray
and he just loses it and
every time he he would leave at least
he'd come right back to me and he'd hold
his arm out and say you want to pit Bill
Murray
yes I do yes I'd like to that don't
worry and so then we struck up another
conversation we talked about Letterman
of course you know my hero in life and
we talk about golf we talked about his
first pitch at the Cubs game years ago
when he throws the ball over the fence
um you know we had we talked to good I I
mean I'm not trying to overstate this a
good half an hour and I just had this
moment of like I I just
I was in awe the whole the rest of the
night the rest of the night just kept
spinning around saying to myself I
cannot believe
and the thing I didn't tell him you see
all these posters behind me well the one
that's hanging in my house in
Chattanooga right now is a poster of
Bill Murray
I've got a Bill Murray poster in my
house and on the bottom it says ladies
and gentlemen Bill Murphy signed Dave
Letterman and you know he's just been on
a Mount Rushmore of my life for I got
since the moment I ever saw him on
Letterman so
um
so with all that being said you know
bear you know me well enough there's
only one left there's only one more left
who is it I think he just said his name
it's Dave yeah I only need one more and
I'll be and I'll be Lord Taco happy
check check me out of this life I'm good
to go I only need Dave and I've got the
I've got the Mount Rushmore of human
beings that I have been able to meet in
my life and that's I I can't believe it
I just can't believe it and when you
when you think about all the like the
Crazy Bill Murray stories that you've
heard right right one you know he shows
up at a
at a frat party and starts doing dishes
right you know
um I had a guy uh you walk he walks up
to somebody and takes a bite out of
their hamburger and just walks away you
know like I know some of these have like
created their own living legend right
but it's because he's a you know he's
that character he's exactly that person
and so one time I heard the story from a
buddy of mine who goes uh he goes I was
I was standing at this I can't remember
where he was like the map room or chart
room I mean it was Matt it was map room
in um in Chicago and all of a sudden he
had these hands go over his eyes from
behind and and whispered into his ear
the guy behind him says this is Bill
Murray no one will ever believe you
[Laughter]
and so he turns around and sees Bill
Murray just walk away from him I mean he
just that kind of guy and he's exactly
exactly that person when you meet him I
I was I've been giddy for two weeks ever
since that's cool that's cool when I saw
the pictures I I think I told Taco I
said I'm not surprised it seems like
something Bill Murray would do he loves
that kind of stuff yeah it's totally
appropriate yeah
yeah exactly good for you yeah well I
mean look I mean if you see Bill Murray
you have to figure out a way to get a
picture and I just didn't want to do the
regular I don't know
I'm not sure I would have laid hands on
him but good for you
I don't know if a petting was where I
would go
advise it for most people let me let me
okay do you think that he's going to
remember the PBR guy or the guy that pet
him randomly on a Friday night you're
lucky there wasn't you know Authority
authorities called yeah
he touched me
he found he found it to be a kick um you
know what you said you said it right
there that's that's my people always ask
me if I got autographs or whatever you
know and I'm always like yeah if I feel
like they connected like they're gonna
remember me it's a it's I'm it's
memorable otherwise yeah yeah you know
yeah I've never really been I've never
really been a picture guy I've never
really taken these moments to sort of
document because they're more they're
more fun when I get to tell you guys
right like the the moment is so much
more important than a picture I I guess
because I live in the world of radio and
I just like having a sword to tell
instead of a picture to show like that
picture does me no good yeah yeah I I uh
not that sounds like a
you have a story now I have a story but
I mean I got to talk to Lucinda Williams
two weeks ago oh I love Lucinda Williams
couldn't get her off the phone man we
laughed we started I in fact I quit
recording we just started talking it was
it was really cool that's great yeah and
then she's such a sweetheart too isn't
it ah she's so great you know she
laughed and and I I you know yeah it's
the same thing it was it wasn't bad I
bet she has a great giggle
yes it's a hearty real uh honest laugh
it was really cool at this point in her
life she's a grandmother right
oh I don't know about that I don't know
if I don't know I don't think so did you
pet her we always assume you know he
breathed yeah
if she talks about her dad a lot which
is really cool her dad very influential
in her life so that was cool
and then um is that an age thing though
do you get to a certain age and you
start talking about your parents a lot
because you probably become the parental
unit that you always saw as a child
well you know he was a poet and uh she's
written a song about
um a musical artist that he would take
her to go see when he would play in New
Orleans
and so that's what triggered it but I've
talked to her twice in New Orleans she
grew up in a lot of places she lived in
New Orleans for a while she lived in
Macon when she was little
um and uh she's in Nashville now yeah I
know
um she used to come up to Chattanooga
Rock City loved it loved it was she and
her siblings were kids the dad dad would
bring him up here
so I think I think about Rock City a lot
when I uh it's very mad men you know I
think about Don Draper in those episodes
of him just getting in the car and going
on like road trips with the kids you
know back in the 60s in the late 60s
Barry you know what you were 40. uh the
late 60s early 70s horse and buggy yeah
you you get in the car and you drive in
these roadside attractions that are not
around anymore you know rock city was
way up there right that was the place
where you stopped and and just let the
kids do something for a few hours
instead of sitting in the car that's
right and talking about marketing I mean
those barns I mean it's crazy everybody
knows about Rock City
[Music]
stop it really I didn't know that yeah
yep t7 States so so what what all have I
missed in the last few weeks I feel like
uh there's so much to catch up on
no we were we were geared up to talk to
a bunch of bands on Sunday for Moon
River and then uh the storm came got
rained out got canceled it was fun it
was fun to be able to go to a festival
saw a bunch saw several you know
Bonnaroo friends
um yeah we had a mini Bonnaroo mini
Lindsay and Zach
Daniel and Sharla and who else Dewar was
there Chrissy was there yeah yeah it was
a lot of fun and then rained out and we
you know we did last week's podcast on
that oh by the way yeah yeah uh yeah I
mean you and I haven't spoken and I I'm
glad we are because I we made the point
I hope in that podcast of you know this
was uh Live Nation C3 and AC getting it
right uh my daughter uh got her refund
yesterday
so what is that nine days ten days you
know after the cancellation already has
her refund
for half that's pretty good that's real
good you know we we picked on them and
picked on them so they got it right
yeah and I think that um along the way I
think you start realizing the
the reason why they're able to do
something like this is because of the
very thing that we all complain about
yep because they're so big they're able
to take uh take something like this on
the chin
no question yeah it doesn't happen if
it's a you know small outfit if it's
buried yeah
vendor we uh yes we're not really taking
the hit yeah every can has my face on it
yeah so that's the that's the the plus
side of having a Live Nation behind it
uh but also as I was told by several
people they learned they learned their
lesson you know they they came in well
you know with Bonnaroo we all there was
talk and certain complaints that the
communication wasn't great that it took
forever to get refunds
um you know it just the things that you
and I and and taco we've all bragged
about for four years four and a half
years they seem to kind of lose their
way a little bit you know by focusing on
The Fan Experience is what it seemed to
be and uh
man they seem to get it right wouldn't
you agree Russ I mean that was uh oh
absolutely they they did everything
right they didn't even have to give
refunds yeah I'm not like that not and
it wasn't just 50 of your or a full
refund if it was one day of your ticket
it was fees and all so I mean they
really uh granted it's a much smaller
Festival it's a singer-songwriter
festival you know it has it had some
things different than Bonnaroo but it
was essentially the same people running
it
um who did you miss on Sunday after it
got canceled
a Band of Horses Leon Bridges oh yeah uh
there was like three bands that played
and then they had to cancel yeah it was
right in the middle of Sammy Ray's uh
set and then she was the one we were
scheduled to talk to later that
afternoon yeah we had interviews lined
up with Sammy Ray wilderado and uh Ben
from uh Band of Horses
so it was just disappointing yeah but it
was you know nobody more disappointed
than a Mr Brian Stone who is a massive
Band of Horses fan and called me in a
fit of rage because he I had all so much
material bro he did work
excited ready to go for Ben the one time
he does research
actual work the one time he knows what
he's talking about exactly exactly he'd
put in some good research and was ready
and and had questions and everything and
it didn't happen yeah but I like it like
I told uh Taco I mean you know it'll pay
off we'll talk to him some somewhere
down the line they'll remember uh they
actually reached out his management
reached out that Sunday afternoon to see
if we could meet somewhere and so they
were you know it was all everything was
cool yeah everything was cool the whole
thing other than the weather you know it
was just a really I like it went from a
real it went from a real Downer you know
thinking that all this is canceled to
actually being a really uh good time and
a good sense a lot of it's got I gotta
imagine is is thanks to Drew Holcomb huh
no question
um that that was mentioned several times
by a couple of people in our podcast
that you know having somebody who is the
face and the curator
is different and uh he's also a nice guy
you know you'll hear in the interview
that you're we're about to play the with
wild rivers uh it was actually and I had
forgotten this his son was born the
weekend of Moon River
uh the first year they came first year
yeah Ellie was very pregnant sang and
then went home and had a baby uh
literally and they held his fourth
birthday party backstage where we were
doing our interviews so yeah here
clapping and cheering and singing and
well I'll let Lord taco be the judge and
whether or not they had a baby or not
that's that's his Department there were
a couple of uh he identified a couple of
babies
yeah wow migrants just just to clarify
because I mean Lord Taco is the expert
at identifying babies are there any
babies on this call right now
no wow see I would I would have guessed
differently he's 100 simply it he's 100
he's sorry I've never got it wrong I
mean you're in the Hall of Fame of
identifying all I have to do is see it
and then I can tell you if it's a baby
or not didn't tell you it's a baby I I
don't know how you do it yeah how you do
it you know all right knows his beer and
he knows his babies yeah yes he does no
beer
um
so are we in the uh are we in the world
where it's Bonnaroo rumors season yet
are we in rumor
chatter season
I think it started close can someone
tell me who the the rumored uh
Headliners are do we have anything like
that yet
if there's any big rumors or not oh yeah
okay okay great which we were hoping
you'd tell us we've got to be rage right
rage yeah well I mean I don't know why
not I've made my demands demands that's
right I told everybody on the show last
week that the reason you were not around
was because you were on a hunger strike
that you hadn't
you hadn't eaten red meat since uh you
made your demand so for the year is yes
right I've been making demands for 13
years that's right um I uh so I did I
did find out who the Saturday headliner
is and I'm pretty sure the Friday late
night was told to me as well they don't
know if it was definitely Friday uh late
night or if it's The Closer on Friday or
on Sunday rather so I don't know and and
I don't necessarily feel the most conf
or comfortable uh saying it out loud
just yet but
um boy if that rumor mill was going
around we really could make that a lot
easier this conversation
um but I'll just put it this way uh the
Saturday headliner is
gonna be massive
um and then the Friday late night is
everything that we've wanted for years
or at least berries wanted for years uh
and it's it's a perfect perfect
combination and these two bands alone I
think make um uh the Bonnaroo faithful
very very very happy yeah good yeah I'm
excited from what you told me uh
I also wanted to say I had some some
folks reach out uh we're I'm going to
talk next week with some folks with uh
Live Nation and uh they have some some
prizes some plans they're working on and
we're gonna hopefully set up a podcast
so okay looking forward to uh surprises
as in as in like campsite adjustments
I'm not exactly sure it was very it was
very short note just basically can we
talk next week about some things we've
got in the works and uh and perhaps uh
do a podcast so okay I was thrilled that
they reached out and uh let's talk about
it yeah I'm I'm very excited about it so
I hate to you know tease like that and
but I don't know that any more than that
yet so the other the other thing that I
was going to ask uh I we did an event
um a couple weeks ago maybe a couple
months ago I was talking to uh
their managers and we were just over
some beers and that birthed this idea of
let's have the Smashing Pumpkins on a
tiny stage in New York and uh do it all
for free
um the radio station was going to go
through a couple of different things
that didn't pan out but uh the the show
remained and we had it over the uh over
the last week last Thursday
the thing that I was thinking about this
whole time during the show was
someone fact checked me has Smashing
Pumpkins never been to Bonnaroo
um
I don't think so I I don't think so
either and that kind of like took me for
a it kind of took me took me back for a
second I can't really understand why
I don't know this is one of the bands on
the Mount Rushmore of rock music and yet
uh no Bonnaroo and frankly I don't know
if I remember any real Festival they've
been on before maybe it's just a a Billy
Corgan thing that when you start
thinking that they have a new album
coming out that has 33 tracks
you know that they're putting it out in
three parts
and it comes out all by April I gotta
imagine that you know but why would
Smashing Pumpkins not be on their radar
for Bonnaroo the show is fantastic now I
know a lot of Smashing Pumpkins die
hards get a little irritated because the
set list doesn't really ever change but
I don't care I'd never seen them before
can you believe it one of the great
bands of all time and I've I had never
seen Smashing Pumpkins and it didn't
even occur to me that I had never seen
them until like Wednesday yeah when you
say that I don't remember seeing them on
other festival lineup either I don't
know maybe they just don't do a lot of a
lot of that sort of thing I don't know
you know we've always said it's all
about timing
um and availability and all that so I
don't know I don't think they've ever
been there though I can't recall seeing
them on a lineup
yeah man that show was so good oh God it
was good
um all right what oh the other thing
that uh we never got to was the
Woodstock documentary I finally watched
that Dad I finally watched it what'd you
think
um I liked it better than the other one
yeah I liked it better because it felt
um not as
um I don't know maybe maybe I felt like
it was less accusatory
and put everything on
the bands and that they they sort of
expanded sort of the blame a little bit
but also the part that
I think that I I take away from it the
most people really had a good time
aside from the people like the people
who had their their complaints everybody
in that documentary that they asked but
would you do it again yeah yeah I wanna
I it was it one of the great weekends of
your life yeah yeah it was I mean by
being bringing back to Brian Stone he
was there too and he remembers it being
a struggle
but one of the best weekends of his life
yeah well it's pretty epic I mean it
pretty memorable I would have to believe
I could I could see that once it was
over and you were past it I could see
that being part of it the things that
stood out to me uh and I forgot that we
hadn't talked about it was how much just
what we the opposite of what we were
saying about Moon River uh the The Fan
Experience the fan was not you know
considered and
so how far festivals came if that was 99
Bonnaroo started in 2001 right
um one or two so three years later yeah
it was two so three years later
you know they they go from basically
that [ __ ] show on a on a Tarmac you know
nothing but concrete and asphalt
little not enough bathrooms not enough
food not enough water you know all of
those things to you know Bonnaroo had
its issues the first year too but uh it
was good enough that people wanted to go
back and they continue to fix it that
and the other thing that stood out to me
and I I had asked you if your wife
Hillary had seen it
I remember thinking
just how different uh women females have
been treated
I mean they were treated so badly at
Woodstock you know per both of those
documentaries
and um
I know there have been issues at Bonner
anytime you get that many people to
gather and alcohol there's going to be
some issues but I remember second or
third year they're just thinking how
different everything was in that regard
you know what I mean it was nothing for
a female to
go to a show by yourself
whereas just a few years earlier you
would have never you know done that
because guys are just pigs basically
I think that you read brand values you
determine what you want your brand
values to be and the audience will
follow you so if you espouse a certain
level of
um like Bonnaroo does positivity hope
inclusiveness then that's what you're
going to get from the audience if you
if you breed commercialism
you know that's that's what you're going
to get from the audience so you
your mission statement means a lot to
even from 2000 to now and I think that
the other thing too that
these things have benefited from is
failure they failed a lot in 99 and
frankly you know I bet Bonnaroo would
even tell you and our guys that we've
talked to in years past have sort of
hinted at it failure really sort of
fixes a lot of blind spots sure you know
that that complete rain out in 2004 that
you know was an epic disaster at
Bonnaroo turned out to be the reason why
they made all the improvements on the
farm and and the reason probably why
they
um maybe not the reason but a reason why
they bought the place so they could
never have to worry about having a
complete
disaster that was that rain out in 2004
which by the way
um we will be talking about a lot in the
coming weeks and months because uh 2004
will be on somebody's mind I don't know
how to say this without giving it away
anyway just just remember the the rain
out in 2004 because it's going to be a
big part of the conversation uh come the
spring while we're talking about
Bonnaroo uh 2023. very cool
I don't want to give too much away
because it's it's gonna it's gonna it
will probably be my uh Christmas present
to Barry it's a good one then
you're my hero so so uh yeah so so I
think there
the Bonnaroo people were very smart in
that and maybe the Coachella people too
we just don't know him as well they were
so smart to pay attention to all of the
problems because
you could have saw that and said no no
we're done uh let's there's no possible
way we're gonna put ourselves in this
position frankly
how they even got an insurance policy
after seeing the disaster that was uh
that was but by the way it wasn't
supposed to be Bonnaroo it was supposed
to be
what the hell was it originally
yeah and it didn't work
well it was ichiku which was an AC thing
and then when Superfly reached out to
Ashley at ac they were going to do
Bonnaroo uh the reason it's at on in
Manchester is because Ashley had done
ichiku and knew the knew the farm knew
it would work so I mean it was I don't
think it was always supposed to be
ichiku because ichiku was not hugely
successful
um so I've got I've got a whole dog pile
sitting in my lap right now they uh I
wish I could show you the faces that are
bothering the hell out of me right now
guys what do you want from me I can't do
anything for you right now I have to
give all my attention to Barry and taco
not you too I'm sorry
yeah I'm sorry about them
um but yeah I like I like this sorry
excuse me I like the second one so much
better I mean that's essentially the
same story but I just felt so it was a a
little bit better of a um you know yeah
story telling of the story and you know
associating blame sort of everywhere not
just any artist I felt like the artist
got a lot of the the bum rat the first
go-around they did and I don't remember
who maybe it was Pondo pointed out that
they really focused on just the one
stage there were two stages there and we
never really saw much from the other
stage
um don't know what was going on there
but yeah and I also appreciated the way
that they
told like they put the plot out they
explained to me what the lay of the land
was better than the first one I didn't
really know anything about that Hangar I
didn't really know how everything was
set up and the way that this podcast
started was because we were obsessed
with You Know chords on the on the farm
and how they built a a festival site I
look at that Festival site that they
explained in that second uh documentary
and I just say to myself
ugh yeah I know oh that's what I mean it
sounds awful three years three years
later it went from you know that to
you know the beginning of what we know
now like I said they didn't get it all
right that first year at Bonnaroo but
they got it pretty close well the other
thing too is like back in that day so it
was 2003 I went to Music Midtown in
Atlanta and it was the exact same thing
it was just a big parking lot yeah oh it
was miserable yeah miserable yeah Now
The Fan Experience that's what I mean
like you said that's why we started the
show and that's what we focus on
um it's just that was what was
fascinating to me to think about that it
was it seemed so so long ago but in a
way it wasn't you know well I remember
in the first years and I think that
we'll probably talk more about those
early years
um in the coming months but I remember
because I had never really camped before
I remember thinking that I needed to
come with like a bow and arrow I was
going into the Wilderness and I had no
idea what I was doing like
um I need to take a toolbox in case I
need to build a shed or something I
don't know what I was thinking but I
really came with all of these
expectations of
um I might die here yeah no I I was
petrified that first year I was I'm with
you I I tried to Think Through yeah
toolbox uh you know everything more food
than you could possibly eat in four days
you know because you're going to the
Moon basically already is what it it
felt like
it did and I I like I I love the kids
now that go and they're on their third
fourth fifth Bonnaroo I just and I'm not
trying to be back in my day kid but um
man in 2003 my first bottle I just
looked around thinking to myself is when
I prepared for it
what do I do I don't know anything about
any of this how do I even how do I even
yeah it's like going to the moon it's
like well what do I what do I take to go
to space I need everything yeah I need
everything I gotta take everything yeah
yeah I might as well pack up my cat yeah
oxygen you need it all yeah I get that
there's uh people around you that are
going to have it and like I said they've
developed too they you know and we leave
you know we can actually leave and go to
Walmart if we have to that that's a
another thing that's changed so I don't
remember that Walmart existing by the
way in 2003. I don't know if it did or
not I don't remember anything existing
by the way I uh yeah nothing about that
space is the same as it was in 2003.
true except for maybe the Waffle House I
think the waffle house is still there
true yeah anyway it it was interesting
to see that and and consider how things
have changed and developed so yeah I'm
glad but what else uh what else isn't
going on what's going on in uh Taco's
life what have I missed
just just a lot of uh car stuff and and
streaming and Twitch streaming yeah I've
been doing uh twitch Barry have you been
watching a show yet have you been
watching I watched a little bit I sure
did and I'm with you I I don't get it I
don't get it but I but I I feel like it
is like the best public access late
night TV show uh I'm obsessed with it I
I feel like that's really what it is
yeah
what was that guy
we just celebrated 420 followers that's
the weed number I do
yes we know that that's the lead number
uh it reminds me so much of like early
Tom Green yeah yeah yeah
that's a good way to put it yeah I just
love it so much it's so goofy and I have
no idea what I'm watching I really have
no idea what I'm watching but I'm into
it every time so what is this um what is
this interview that we're gonna put on
Barry who are we talking to wild rivers
um what was it um yeah they were great
they're Canadian uh originally and uh
they're fascinating they are now uh
Devin is moving to Los Angeles
uh Khalid is moving to Nashville
and Andrew Wright is uh going to stay in
uh Canada and they're going to be a band
so we talked about that a little bit
um I mean it's not uncommon we had
Daniel we had Daniel from Interpol come
by the station the other day and that's
how they operate yeah I know you know I
asked him straight up it's like I mean
are you guys friends he's like well yeah
but as much as friends can be when we
live in
seven different time zones yeah right
yeah that's that it's not that unusual
um but they do they don't plan to record
uh
uh separately they want to be together
when they record because they did I
actually I'm actually glad you brought
that up because the thing that is so
Charming about Phoenix is that uh which
by the way I did an interview with
Phoenix that you can go back and watch
on the station website or something but
um the thing that's so Charming about
Phoenix is that they've been around 25
years they were best friends then and
they're still best friends they vacation
together they all live near each other
and you know he's married as Sophie
Coppola you know I mean yeah so and
they're all and they're all just you
know hanging around the family you know
the kids are the kids are and I asked
him straight at Tomas I asked him I said
uh does it is it kind of weird that
somebody like me brings up the fact that
you guys are best friends so often
it kind of feels like you're the white
you're you're the only you're the
Unicorn you're the white unicorn of the
music industry and that you're the only
band that hangs out in their friends and
that vacations together he's like yeah
it feels kind of strange because it
always feels like that was what it's
supposed to be and and you just don't
see it very often there aren't many you
two I know those guys are all saying
they're all friends and and vacation
together and hang out
um so I've read and they you know didn't
tell me personally but it is rare and
it's um
you know you got to like each other
that's one of the things that uh I don't
know if you do
well it's one of the things we talked
with Matt Carney about you know you got
to be on the road uh he's like you know
you might be really good guitar player
for 90 minutes but I got to see you the
other 22 and a half hours so you know
like maybe maybe it's maybe it's a
status level maybe you have to get along
when you are
um you know a mid-tier act but you know
it's not like The Black Keys get along
yeah well Oasis The Kinks yeah I know
there's all kinds of examples uh but I
mean if you're going to spend that much
time with somebody
um I I but moving that far away I mean
that we kind of joked about it with the
the guys from Wild Rivers if they
couldn't they couldn't pick you know any
farther apart any places on the planet
no it's almost as if it was on purpose
exactly can I get it far away from us I
could move yeah and how you know Alaska
this time of year
what's that tour going to look like
where are you going to meet in the
middle and they kind of laughs man I've
been looking at this piece of property
in Russia yeah like
it was kind of funny they were super
nice and uh like I said you'll hear uh
Drew and Ellie having the birthday party
they had a three-legged race and did all
kinds of stuff that was kind of cool
yeah our interview got kind of crashed
by a four-year-old's party yeah that was
all right though that was a lot of fun
and once again as we said before
brianstone was a huge help and
um everybody was I mean we it was
everybody was you know it's funny we
we've talked about how you get all
stressed about these things because
you're not sure if you're going to get
access and what access and all that but
it always works out better than you know
better than you hope so
thanks to all those people you guys yeah
you guys are the stress balls not me I
don't oh I know guys oh we had the yeah
we had the Jitters right before
everything you know because we didn't
weren't sure if we're gonna get this or
that and of course it all worked out so
and yeah loading equipment no I mean
it's you know it's just there's
Logistics but uh Sue Marcus with the PR
stunt she was great and lined everything
up and uh Hannah I mean it was you know
yeah okay good everything worked as long
as they should yeah I feel like one of
these days you're just gonna ask like a
like a wheelchair there you can somebody
just wheel you around and motorized
wheelchair you'd be great with that you
know I got the golf cart at Riverbend I
got golf carted around all over that was
pretty sweet I kind of was
kind of waiting for that from at Moon
River never happened no well you know
next time you're pointing at your hip
just a bad hip I know that hit all right
next year okay all right let's get into
the wild nervous thing and uh after that
we'll talk to you soon how about that
great all right
we have more special guests with us
today we have Devin Andrew and Khaled
from wild rivers you guys just finished
your Set uh did you have a good time
it was awesome big old crowd people up
on the bridge singing along super fun
have you been to Chattanooga before
I don't think so I think this is our
first time here
you guys are from Canada Toronto Canada
yeah is that still home yeah home for
most of us cows making a move to
Nashville and dev's making a move to LA
but I'm keeping the home base
you couldn't find any farther points
we're trying to be International we got
outposts everywhere and we'll slowly
take over the world is our plan what's
taking you to La first mostly the
weather Canadian Winters are not
something that I was built for despite
being Canadian
um also just the music industry the
water the hiking all that stuff
was there is there something specific
about LA or you just I'm leaving Canada
and I think just I meet so many creative
people there so many songwriters moved
down there and uh I don't actually know
that many musicians in Toronto anymore
so it's such a good creative hub for me
to be able to collaborate with people
and it's very inspiring and we've all
spent time as a band down there we we
lived there for four months while we
were writing our albums so we're
familiar with it and uh I just loved it
so I wanted to stay
and yet you chose Nashville yeah I like
La too I like the vibe I think I prefer
the vibe of Nashville and that I grew up
in a small town and it it's a very small
town and you run into everybody you know
at every bar every coffee shop and
people are just really chill down to
Earth but incredible incredible
songwriters so have you driven in
Nashville oh yeah well if you've never
driven in Toronto Nashville is a
cakewalk oh wow Toronto is a thing okay
from from 2 to 6 P.M every day you're
not you're not getting anywhere so
everyone says the natural traffic is bad
but I'm very used to it wow that that
tells me all I need to know about
Toronto yeah that's that's the one one
big Downfall with the Toronto and the
cold weather in the winter but we love
home too
and you're gonna you're staying stand
Stan
I assume you guys are gonna stay as a
band have you talked about how you're
going to make this work yeah I think
we're just gonna plan to get together
before tours and when we're recording
and make kind of little vacations out of
uh writing trips and stuff like that I
mean a lot of bands do it it's not it's
not unprecedented the reality of it is
that we're never home anyways so even US
changing locations like we've been on
tour this entire year so having a home
base is a little less relevant because
we're always doing stuff together all
the time whether we're making a record
whether we're touring
um so yeah I don't think it I don't
think it will be too too tough
let's go back a little bit you guys
started in 2016 right what was the uh
personal how did you get together I'm
always kind of fascinated was it a
eight and a half by eleven poster on a
telephone pole or an ad in a magazine
for a singer
we uh we went to school Devin and I went
to school in a college town a couple
hours outside of Toronto called Kingston
um we went to University there neither
of us studying music but both interested
in music and we were both from the
Toronto area and my my neighbor in first
year the person the girl next door to me
in the in my dorm room
said you have to meet Devin she's an
incredible singer I know you're like
looking to do music stuff so we kind of
got introduced
um and I was working on songs and Dev
was wanting to start a project too so we
kind of just started singing together
and instantly it was Supernatural we
like liked all the same music and kind
of Blended in a very easy way so we kind
of rolled with that all of University
playing coffee shops bars any gig we
could doing little tours slowly focusing
Less on our studies and more on the
music and then by the End by the time we
graduated we're like let's make a go of
this and record an album so we used all
the money that we had made from our bar
gigs to go towards our first record
um and during that time we wanted to
flesh out the song so we built up the
band for the record
um which included Andrew and uh started
working on that record and then it felt
really good and it kind of turned into a
band project and turned we all played
shows together and the it was more than
just a Duo thing so that's when wild
rivers itself really started
at the point when you said I think this
is the tree this is who we are this is
the trio we want to do this what was the
goal I mean when you sat down I assumed
you had a sort of meeting and said what
do we want our sound where do we want to
go uh what what's the direction for the
band what was that conversation I don't
know if we've ever had like explicit
musical goals we're lucky that we have
all the same taste and we like a whole
bunch of different music
um our goal with the music is just to
have
serve the song song based writing party
all right
[Applause]
I don't know if you guys can see it on
the camera but wow what a great day
I seen one of their children it must be
a birthday this is exciting
all right we might have a happy place
Joy right there yeah okay
that's cute we might have to talk over
him that's okay that's cool that's neat
but I'm saying there's stuff
our musical specific specifically what
we're doing musically we've allowed
ourselves to
draw outside the lines and not really be
tied down to we're going to be this
Americana band like we want to make
whatever music that we're feeling at the
time and we have career goals and
playing festivals like this and playing
um our Dream venue in Toronto Massey
Hall was a was a big goal that we just
did this year so
um it's only in recent years that we're
kind of realizing some of our big band
goals which is awesome
[Music]
has that changed at all I mean as you've
grown do you do you now sit and talk
more specifically about what you want to
do next
every every few years will kind of check
in with each other and be like okay this
is working to a certain extent this is
the direction we're moving in what do we
want out of this and how can we kind of
like narrow our Focus to get there but I
think
since we started we were just kind of
trying to make music and trying to play
shows and whatever that meant we were
happy with it so as it has started to
evolve it's allowed us to kind of like
expand what our goals actually are
because we we were always just thinking
about what was right in front of us like
okay this next tour how can we make this
the best tour we can
how can we make this record sound how we
want it to sound and I think that maybe
is is why things have worked for us
because we're kind of focused on the
music and focused on the shows
um and keeping those authentic and
consistent and that has opened up some
doors for us which has been great
Festival like this
that has to kind of help right it's got
to be a boost
it's the best we love it this is what we
want to do like this is what one of the
goals we wrote down when we started the
band was to play outside the packed
crowd people singing our songs and that
happened today it was amazing it's so
fun and I I don't think it will ever get
old
another big goal for us which is just
recently been unlocked was uh we always
wanted to tour in some kind of bus
situation and this is our first like
time in a in a bus so we just woke up
outside of the stage here and it was
it's a beautiful thing
how does that work or how's it going to
work La Toronto it's gonna be a long
pickup route yeah I think we'll probably
fly to one central location and then
start the bus from there yeah I figure
all of our families are from Toronto so
like
we're gonna be home kind of
all the time as well and we all love
each City that we're in so we'll see
maybe a little La trip before the next
door Nashville trip
a lot of Zoom meetings that kind of
thing hopefully not we did we kind of
did half of our record in the pandemic
uh a lot remotely because in Toronto the
lockdown was so severe that we couldn't
see each other for for a couple months
and yeah nobody likes Zoom meetings no
one wants to make music like that is
honestly pretty hard to that stage of
making a record we were apart but then
we were able to we actually went back to
the town that we met at University
hold up in a studio there and finish the
record which was so much better than
sending files back and forth like so
much of what we do is like a dynamic
live thing so it was nice to actually
make music in the same room again
you talk about being on the bus and I
before we actually started recording I
think you were talking about you're
excited to go out and watch some music
today so I we won't keep you much longer
but who who in particular are you
looking forward to seeing and are you
going to be here tomorrow as well
I'm stoked to see the national they're
one of my favorite bands and uh Peter
cadis who produced our last record
produced most of the Nationals record so
it'll be cool to see them
um what about you uh Burston moroney's
great we've put down a few festivals
with him this Summer but I haven't
actually been able to see the set so I'm
excited for that we love Briston yeah
he's awesome yeah we uh Briston is a
three-time guest on our show yeah no way
it's it's technically two because I
forgot to hit record oh [ __ ]
but he's so sweet yeah he seems like
he's forgiving oh he was so great he got
up and he had this kind of yeah I'll do
it again so run it back so we're huge
huge fans plus he's from Knoxville which
is not far from here but uh we're fans
of his music but also now he's you know
yeah
place
I think we did
yeah at the very least we had a good
conversation yeah we appreciate it well
I know you guys want to get out and hear
some music so anything else that you
wanted anything coming up where can
people see you next if they're during
the whole month every major city in
America will be there
um this is going to be our last big
stretch of touring before we take a
break and then go into album mode so
yeah if you want to catch a wild River
show look on our website
wildriversmusic.com and
we got a new album too it's called
Sidelines you can find us on all of the
Google things and hopefully see you at a
show or listen to the music absolutely
cool Devin Andrew cow thank you thank
you thank you very nice thank you
[Music]
consequence podcast Network